[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis
guten abend und herzlich willkommen für
den sport im studio und norbert lehmann
einen guten eindruck von mir blicken wir
auf die großen themen dieser sendung
frust bei tausenden bahnkunden der
streik der lokführer sorgt für enorm
viele zugausfälle und gewaltige
verspätungen
taliban auf dem vormarsch weil die
islamisten in afghanistan immer weitere
städte erobern stopp deutschland jetzt
die abschiebungen dorthin
und verrückt nach messi frenetisch
feiern die fans in paris ihren neuen
superstar
viele züge fallen aus andere verspäten
sich wer mit der deutschen bahn fährt
braucht seit heute morgen viel geduld
denn der streik der
lokführergewerkschaft gdl hat erhebliche
auswirkungen auf den bahnverkehr in ganz
deutschland besonders betroffen die
fernverbindungen nach konzernangaben
vielen 75 prozent der züge aus im
regionalverkehr waren es rund 60 prozent
weniger
viele bahn vor nur um einen oder zwei
stunden takt melis ikea berichtet
der ärger bei vielen bahnreisenden und
pendler innen ist groß bundesweit sitzen
fahrgäste an bahnhöfen fest ich finde
von unverschämter muss ich sagen
das einfach jetzt in situationen
abzuziehen dortmund haben sie gesagt
sondern wir reißen aber köln plötzlich
endstation also ich hab's nie erlebt
schweizerin und ich finde es total blöd
ich bin da kein freund von ich möchte
auch mehr geld und kann mich da habe ich
auf dem hosenboden setzen hoffen dass es
kommt seit dieser nacht bestreikt die
gewerkschaft deutscher lokomotivführer
den personen und güterverkehr
trotz ferienende in vielen bundesländern
sie wissen dass es keine gute zeit gibt
in der man den arbeitskampf im eisenbahn
system machen kann wir bestreiken die
deutsche bahn ag weil seit 7 juni die
tarifverhandlungen gescheitert sind weil
das angebot das er sei ja immer wieder
in den vordergrund schiebt und
akzeptabel ist und am ende des tages
verantwortet der bahnkonzern mal zur im
streit auch o2 gehört dass die
auseinandersetzung jetzt auch auf dem
rücken von reisenden stattfindet die gdl
fordert eine lohnerhöhung einen corona
bonus und eine änderung der terry
vertragslaufzeiten auf 28 monate die
bahn klagt sie habe schon nach dem
ersten streiktag wirtschaftliche
verluste wir fordern natürlich auch die
gdl auf an den verhandlungstisch
zurückzukehren wo wir ja auch schon
relativ nahe beieinander waren wir reden
über lohnentwicklungen von 3,2 prozent
wenden wir auch über die zeitliche folge
noch nicht einig sind oder ein paar
andere dinge auch nicht aber es ist
völlig überzogen und unnötig gewesen
erst am freitag dürfte sich der
bahnverkehr langsam normalisieren und
der streit zwischen bahn und gdl ist
damit noch lange nicht gelöst
und kommende woche will die gdl über
weitere streiks entscheiden wenn auch
ihre bahn heute ausgefallen ist oder sie
verspätet am ziel gekommen sind in der
zdf- heute- app können sie nachschauen
welche rechte sie haben ob ihnen etwa
eine entschädigung zusteht und was sie
beachten müssen
und wir schauen nach afghanistan dort
haben die taliban heute offenbar eine
weitere provinz eingenommen ohne die
internationalen truppen die fast
komplett abgezogen sind scheint die
afghanische armee den islamisten nicht
viel entgegensetzen zu können immer
wieder gibt es berichte von gräueltaten
die die taliban verüben angesichts der
sicherheitslage wird deutschland nun
erst einmal keine menschen mehr nach
afghanistan abschieben klaus brodbeck
vielleicht haben solche bilder den
innenminister zum einlenken gebracht
taliban auf ihrem brutalen vormarsch
hier im afghanischen fahrer die
außenminister reagiert erleichtert ich
begrüße die entscheidung des
innenministers die heute getroffen
worden ist wir standen auch in den
letzten tagen innerhalb der
bundesregierung in diesen fragen in
einem engen kontakt am ende war
deutschland international isoliert nur
seehofer wollte offenbar weiter
abschieben zwei stunden vor seiner
kehrtwende diese dass sein entspreche
noch bekräftigen dass bmi ist weiterhin
der auffassung dass es menschen in
deutschland gibt die das land verlassen
sollten so schnell wie möglich
unaufhaltsam nehmen die taliban stadt um
stadt ein die opposition fordert schon
seit wochen massive heute entschied wer
kommt spät aber es ist wichtig dass er
jetzt kommt denn wir sehen ja alle wie
die lage sich in afghanistan zuspitzt
und was vor allem für die menschen dort
bedeutet und natürlich auch für die
menschen die möglicherweise abgeschoben
worden
zunehmend bedroht sind auch ehemalige
ortskräfte und deren familien ein teil
wird bereits nach deutschland in
sicherheit gebracht zu wenige zu langsam
sagen experten
das erste ist dass dort schutzbedürftige
menschen rausgeholt werden sind lokale
ortskräfte
die für die bundeswehr gearbeitet haben
und das zweite ist dass menschen die
jetzt zu uns nach deutschland kommen und
schutz brauchen die als afghanistan
kommt diesen auch erhalten zuständig
auch hier das innenministerium seehofer
selbst äußert sich heute vor kameras
nicht
es sind zwei der umstrittensten neuen
corona maßnahmen die beim bund länder
treffen gestern beschlossen wurden zum
einen dass sich ungeimpfte nun testen
lassen müssen wenn sie zur veranstaltung
wollen die drinnen stattfinden ins
restaurant wollen oder in die sporthalle
und zum anderen dass die meisten
ungeimpften die tests selber bezahlen
müssen hermann bern berichtet viele
urlauber sind da auch jene die einfach
mittagspause machen es ist wieder was
los in den kieler restaurants
grundsätzlich begrüßte chef die
geplanten neuen regeln für nicht
geimpfte auch wenn das hier für alle
mehr arbeit bedeutet ich finde es
generell eine eine gute maßnahme glaube
ich um mehr leute zum impfen zu bewegen
was schade ist dass wir in der
gastronomie dann halt wieder mehr
kontrollieren müssen natürlich nimmt das
positive erlebnisse das besuch eines
restaurants ein bisschen ab mehraufwand
mehr bürokratie das fürchten sie auch in
diesem fitnessstudio die zeit nach den
ferien sei besonders wichtig um neue
kunden anzuwerben
durch die beschlüsse von gestern
erwarten sie weitere finanzielle
einbußen ja unabhängig von der
sinnhaftigkeit wird es am ende natürlich
dazu führen dass kunden sich dazu
entscheiden nicht zum training zu kommen
dann vermutlich sich entscheiden zu
kündigen oder auch sich entscheiden gar
nicht erst mitglied zu werden einfach
mal schnell kostenlos testen lassen dass
es bald vorbei ab oktober müssen die
meisten ungeimpften die tests selbst
zahlen mit rund 20 euro rechnen sie hier
viele werden dazu nicht bereit sein so
die einschätzung
wir werden sehen ob wir das testzentrum
dann aufrecht halten können oder ob wir
das eventuell dann auch wieder
kurzfristig schließen das hängt
natürlich davon ab wie viele leute dann
noch zum testen kommen mehrkosten für
nicht geimpfte adolf bauer der präsident
des sozialverbands deutschlands waren
wir fordern von der politik dass sie
auch ärmere im blick hat
gesellschaftliche teilhabe darf nicht
davon abhängen ob menschen sich ein
corona test leisten können noch sind die
tests kostenfrei und jeder der will kann
sich ohne großen aufwand testen lassen
für die besucher von altenpflegeheimen
sollen die tests übrigens auch nach dem
11 oktober kostenlos bleiben das hat das
bundesgesundheitsministerium am
nachmittag klar gestellt ein wichtiges
ziel bei der neuen test pflicht für
ungeimpfte die regierung will sie zum
impfen bewegen denn langsam aber sicher
steigt die bundesweite instituts auf
heute
25,1 während die impfbereitschaft sind
bremen allerdings hat von den
bundesländern die höchste impfquote wie
hat die hansestadt das geschafft dieser
frage ist kai niklasch nachgegangen
im spitzenreiter bremen hat eine neue
altersgruppe ins visier genommen die
zwölf- bis 15-jährigen vor schulbeginn
hat die gesundheitssenatorin jeden
einzelnen dieser gruppe persönlich
anschreiben lassen bremen setzt auf
freiwilligkeit und einsicht im kunde das
jetzt frei von den testen bin unseres
geschäftes den allgemeinen schutz hierzu
und halt
ja dass man ein bisschen mehr freiheit
die freiheit sich impfen zu lassen
nutzen im land bremen mehr menschen als
anderswo 65,2 prozent sind vollständig
geimpft mobile teams impfen in stadtteil
mit hohem migrantenanteil haben
vorbilder wie hier den imamen und seine
ehefrau in dieser gemeinde in
bremerhaven von einer impfung überzeugen
können weil wir hier auch in der
gemeinde
auch in der muttersprache reden könnten
auch erzählen und erklären wie wichtig
das ist bremer unternehmen halfen dabei
die gesamten messehallen zum größten im
zentrum deutschlands umzubauen vorteile
geringe wartezeiten ein guter service
zufriedene impfwillige ein weiteres
argument für simpson liefern die
jüngsten bund länder beschlüsse
ungeimpfte sollen ab oktober für corona
tests selbst zahlen der aufruf sich
impfen zu lassen bleibt nach wie vor das
wichtigste bis zum 11 oktober ist zeit
sich komplett impfen zu lassen und aus
der test pflicht herauszukommen
christopher gärten haft jedenfalls dass
das kommende schuljahr mit vielen
geimpften deutlich mehr normalität
verspricht als das letzte
vier wochen ist das verheerende
hochwasser
nordrhein-westfalen und rheinland-pfalz
her fast 190 menschen kamen dabei ums
leben noch immer werden mehrere menschen
vermisst viele häuser wurden zerstört
erinnerungsstücke von den fluten
weggespült jena kwon hat in der rureifel
mit menschen über ihre trauer gesprochen
spuren einer naturkatastrophe
auf vielen straßen in der eifel sieht es
von außen wieder aufgeräumt aus doch
viele betroffene beginnen jetzt erst zu
realisieren dass ein geliebter mensch
fehlt andreas beck aus nettersheim hat
in der flut seinen schwiegervater
verloren genau wie alle anderen
betroffenen stand ich wirklich unter
schock dh ich hatte schocksymptome wie
sehstörungen kopfschmerzen und das ist
zach die änderungen sind da aber so
langsam sind die erinnerungen
erinnerungen ein langer prozess den
jeder mensch anders bewältigt und der
oft psychologische betreuung erfordert
es ist wichtig über das geschehene zu
sprechen wie in diesem begegnungscafé
pfarrer erik schumacher hat in den
letzten wochen viele schicksale hautnah
begleitet jetzt ist eine phase der lehre
auch das zum nachdenken kommen und ich
denke da sind wir jetzt immer stärker
auch gefragt als seelsorger weil jetzt
die fragen kommen wie konnte das
passieren warum ist wie geht es weiter
traumabewältigung wird unter experten
weit gefasst auch menschen die ihr hab
und gut verloren haben stehen unter
schock noch immer weiß familie honig aus
blumenthal nicht ob das elternhaus
abgerissen werden muss
wenn man von morgens bis abends
genug zu tun hat kann man das gut weg
schieben nun 80 mal müde und schläft und
dann kommt wieder neuer tag also die
trauerbewältigung wird irgendwann
vielleicht ein paar wochen kommen wenn
der große loch kommt gerade dann ist es
wichtig dass familie soziales umfeld und
notfallseelsorge für die betroffenen da
sind
die feuer im mittelmeerraum bleiben
extrem gefährlich auf der griechischen
halbinsel peloponnes sind viele
waldbrände außer kontrolle italien
kämpft neben feuern auch mit einer
hitzewelle bei temperaturen bis weit
über 40 grad und auch in algerien ist
die lage dramatisch vor allem in der
stark bewaldeten bergregion um die stadt
tizi ouzou
65 menschen kamen ums leben darunter
viele soldaten die zuvor zahlreiche
menschen vor den flammen gerettet hatten
über einen verzweifelten kampf christel
haas es ist nur eines von vielen opfern
denen die retter nicht mehr helfen
konnten helfen den flammen rechtzeitig
zu entkommen hier gab es drei tote im
nachbardorf 4 und viele sind im
krankenhaus mit einfachsten mitteln
kämpfen die bewohner gegen die
feuersbrunst die über sie hereinbrach
doch der starke wind macht alle versuche
zunichte die feuerwehr ist da aber es
fehlt an einsatzkräften und an material
algerien hat keine löschflugzeuge
wir versuchen das feuer einzudämmen wir
tun was wir können gott hilft dass wir
es schaffen werden
diese bilder aus der nacht machen
deutlich wie schwer es ist die brände zu
löschen überall züngeln flammen seit
wochen hat es nicht mehr geregnet es
herrscht notizen alles ist
knochentrocken mehrere brände sind
gleichzeitig ausgebrochen die regierung
spricht von brandstiftung und ruft alle
zur solidarität auf
alle schulen alle hotels und auch alle
privatleute müssen sich um die
betroffenen kümmern sie brauchen
unterkünfte und essen bis das desaster
vorüber ist
auch die eu so einer der größten städte
der region ist der feuerwalze nicht
entkommen die freiwilligen helfer sind
erschöpft frustriert aufgeben aber
wollen sie nicht etliche groß brände
wüten noch in der umgebung doch wegen
der trockenheit wird jetzt ein wichtiges
hilfsmittel knapp das löschwasser
und es brennt nicht nur am mittelmeer
auch in sibirien breiten sich immer mehr
feuer aus welche schweren folgen das hat
das können sie heute abend im
auslandsjournal sehen um 22 uhr 15
und jetzt zu einer entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts
dort ist die afg mit einem eilantrag
gescheitert dabei ging es um die wahl
ins präsidium des bundestags
normalerweise ist dort jede fraktion
vertreten aber alle sechs kandidaten der
fdp bei den anderen abgeordneten
durchgefallen deswegen wollte die partei
dem bundestag zu einem anderen
wahlverfahren verpflichten lassen die
richter sahen aber keinen anlass direkt
einzugreifen
der sudan wird ex präsident omar
al-baschir nach den haag ausliefern
vor dem internationalen strafgerichtshof
soll ihm der prozess gemacht werden es
geht um völkermord kriegsverbrechen und
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit in
darfur konflikt dabei waren laut un
angaben 300.000 menschen getötet worden
nach 30 jahren an der macht wurde al
baschir 2009/10 gestürzt seitdem ist er
in gewahrsam
nach polen wo heftig über die
pressefreiheit gestritten wird mit
folgen denn an dem streit ist jetzt die
regierungskoalition unter führung der
nationalkonservativen pis partei
zerbrochen es geht vor allem um den
populären und regierungskritischen
nachrichtensender tvn dessen
muttergesellschaft gehört einem
us-konzern aber sendelizenzen für nicht
europäer sollen künftig abgeschafft
werden so der plan der regierung dagegen
haben gestern tausende demonstriert sie
sehen die meinungsfreiheit in gefahr
heute hat sich das parlament mit dem
mediengesetz befasst natalie steger aus
warschau es ist ein wahrer krimi im
polnischen parlament mit einem
schmerzhaften dämpfer für die kids die
opposition hielt konnte die abstimmung
verschieben um das umstrittene
mediengesetz der kleine
koalitionspartner hatte die regierung im
streit verlassen den ganzen tag aber
über glaubte die pis die mehrheit
trotzdem zu schaffen das ist ein
wirtschaftliches gesetz das hat nichts
mit redefreiheit zu tun
die pis hat bereits seit jahren den
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk fest in
der hand auch viele regionale zeitungen
und portale die medien reform ist neben
der justizreform ein zentraler punkt der
nationalkonservativen beherrscht alle
staatlichen institutionen und um dieses
system zu festigen müsst ihr die medien
beherrschen
betroffen vor allem die sendergruppe tvn
privat regierungskritische marktanteile
schon lange der pis ein dorn im auge tvn
gehört einem us-konzern aber
sendelizenzen für nicht europäer soll es
künftig nicht mehr geben das wäre das
aus
ist ein weiterer kritischer punkt in dem
anti demokratischen prozess in polen ein
verlassen von haupt prinzipien der
demokratie
große proteste gestern noch gegen das
gesetz jetzt ist die abstimmung
verschoben aber nicht aufgehoben
die pis war siege sicher gewesen dass
sie andere abgeordnete mit
versprechungen in ihr lager zieht wann
nun abgestimmt wird noch offen klar aber
ist durch regieren wird nach dem
absprung des koalitionspartners
schwieriger
und wir kommen jetzt zum sport und damit
zu norbert und zum fußball transfer des
lang und jetzt ist es wirklich offiziell
lionel messi wechselt vom fc barcelona
zu paris st germain und das ablösefrei
der argentinier unterschrieb einen
zweijahresvertrag mit option auf eine
weitere saison von 40 millionen euro
jahresgehalt ist die rede die fans
huldigten ihm heute in paris wie einen
heilsbringer
ihr messias ist da 1 meter 70
argentinischer fußball gott aus
barcelona wo sein denkt man schon
eingerissen wird während auch vor dem
hotel in paris eine messi money herrscht
die angesichts von pandemie und sozialen
problemen in frankreich absurd erscheint
aber zumindest heute real ist der star
musste erst den medizin check bestehen
dann war der transfer perfekt
mein ziel und mein traum ist es wieder
die champions league zu gewinnen und ich
glaube ich bin hier richtig um das noch
mal zu schaffen
die nummer 10 behält nehmer die 30 okay
aber nummer 34 würde genau seinem alter
entsprechen
kurz vor dem fußball bundesliga auftakt
plagen mainz nur fünf große
personalsorgen wegen corona drei spieler
und ein co-trainer wurden positiv auf
kobelt 19 getestet darunter auch zwei
vollständig fünfte das örtliche
gesundheitsamt schickte daraufhin elf
spieler in die häusliche isolation der
liga auftakt gegen leipzig am sonntag
soll dennoch stattfinden
basketball star dennis schröder hat
seinen wechsel zum ende rekordchampion
boston celtics verkündet schröder hält
dort laut medienberichten ein ein jahres
vertrag über 5,9 millionen us-dollar in
der abgelaufenen saison war er
spielmacher bei den los angeles lakers
das war's vom schwarz dankeschön norbert
und millionen kann man ja auch durchs
lotto spielen gewinnen vielleicht haben
sie dieses mal glück gehabt hier die
gewinnzahlen 6 12 22 34 46 49 und die
superzahl 1 weitere gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf
text auf seite 5 157
und wenn das jetzt nicht ihre
glückszahlen waren zumindest die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass die kommende
nacht sternschnuppen sehen ist sehr hoch
mehr dazu und zum wetter morgen hat
gleich katja horne war für sie das heute
können sie um 21 uhr 45 sehen mit claus
kleber und wir sagen auf wiedersehen
machen sie es gut
[Musik]
guten abend heute morgen gab es noch
einige niebel oder dunst felder in
norddeutschland die lösten sich aber
rasch auf und dann waren nur noch wenige
quellwolken unterwegs ist kommt ein
neues hoch heran hoch elfi und so lösen
sich die wolken immer mehr auf das
merken wir schon heute abend und in der
nacht haben wir also gelegenheit mal die
sternschnuppen zu beobachten das sind
die perseiden in dieser und in der
kommenden nacht können bis zu 100 pro
stunde beobachtet werden schauen sie
richtung südosten dann haben sie die
besten chancen die temperaturen heute
nach sinken auf 16 bis 10 grad und
steigen morgen an der nordsee auf 23 24
grad sonst aber wird es sommerlich warm
mit 25 grad auf rügen und bis zu 32 grad
am oberrhein das wird morgen ein sehr
freundlicher sommertag sonnenschein und
wolken wechseln sich ab es gibt
allenfalls kleine quellwolken und nur
über den mittelgebirgen wie er sich im
thüringer wald oder auch im sauerland
kann es mal etwas dichtere wolken
reichen bei südwestwind und sehr
sommerlich wird auch der freitag
allerdings drohen dann am späten
nachmittag und abend einige gewitter aus
den alpen heraus und am samstag wird
dann etwas kühlere luft von nordwesten
herankommen guten ab